the Marvel Cinematic Universe has just
gotten a lot bigger and a whole lot
weirder in all the best possible ways
Captain Marvel managed to burn through a
whole lot of story in a fun fast paced
adventure that sets up some exciting
things for Avengers endgame but a movie
jam-packed of this mature some stuff
might be a little tough to follow from
start to finish if you're looking to
make sense of it all look no further
let's photon blast our way through the
plot of Captain Marvel and explain just
what the ending might mean strap in
major spoilers ahead
Captain Marvel begins on hala the
homeworld of the Kree were introduced to
vs a member of the planets group of star
force warriors and she's been having
nightmares during training sessions with
her mentor and Commander yon rug we
learned that fierce as being trained to
suppress her emotions stopped
questioning her mysterious past and
fight without using her powers which
seems to consist of having superhot
hands the via sucks at emotions
suppressing and she loves a whole hot
hun thing so after a few too many photon
blasts she's sent to be admonished by
the Supreme intelligence the artificial
intelligence leader of the Kree the
supreme intelligence appears differently
to everyone and in this case it appears
as a mysterious woman good thing too
because the supreme intelligence has
actually butt-ugly and also supremely
gross tell me what that thing is
soon via Zeon rogue and the rest of star
force head off on a mission to rescue
and undercover Kree operative but the
whole thing turns out to be a Skrull
ambush and veers has captured and
interrogated with a mind scanning
machine that's where we conveniently
catch more glimpses of EA's hidden
memories and the life she used to have
as an Air Force pilot on earth after
mustering every ounce of willpower
Avia's escapes captivity busts up a
scroll ship and zips down to earth in an
escape pod followed by a squad of scroll
warriors led by a guy named Talos their
mission find a hidden Lightspeed engine
developed by scientists at dr. Wendy
Lawson after crash-landing into a
Blockbuster Video vyas finds herself
stuck on earth so she places a
long-distance call to a Star Force
buddies to tell them she's going after
the scrolls it isn't long before vias
encounters the local law enforcement and
also the feds in the form of Nick Fury
agent of shield just as Fury and his
partner agent Phil Coulson are about to
arrest her for
the crime of busting holes into video
stores she's attacked by a scroll sniper
and gives chase
Furion Colson likewise chaser chaser and
we soon discover that the guy riding
shotgun with fury isn't Colson at all
but a scroll now dead who took his place
once the chase ends a vs seeks answer to
my recently unlocked memories while fury
joins her in a quest to discover the
location of dr. Lawson's engine
meanwhile Shield has been infiltrated
with at least one scroll operative Talos
who's impersonating Furies bus agent
Keller fury and veers head to project
Pegasus to learn about Lawson's work
there they encounter Lawson's cat named
goose a photo of ears as a human fighter
pilot and also there's Dan Scrolls a
fight ensues and vias and fury steal an
experimental flight craft and head to
Louisiana
well they hope to get more answers about
vias former life from Maria Rambo it was
the last person to see lawson and vias
alive on earth the reunion with rambo
and a door to Monaco is bittersweet as
vyas learns a true identity of Carol
Danvers a test pilot who was presumed
dead six years ago after a flight with
Lawson special project went wrong but
even as Rambo fills in the gaps about
her life as Danvers she's unable to
remember as much about her past that
she'd like she can only retain glimpses
of her memories and too many of them are
memories of various failures like
crashing a go-kart or falling from the
ropes course drawing her time in basic
training while gathering more memories
however the house is infiltrated by
Talos and another scroll but this time
instead of threatening numbers and her
friends
Talos offers a truce and an audio
recording of Danvers death here's where
we learn the truth Danvers and Larson
was shot down by a Kree spacecraft
piloted by none other than young rogue
yan rob kills Lawson a secret Cree
operative named Marvel who'd gone broke
and whose experimental project was meant
to peacefully end the kree-skrull war
Danvers realizes she's been fighting for
the wrong side and the create erased our
memories and abducted her from Earth
after she gained her powers a side
effect of her decision to blow up the
engine of Lawsons experimental craft to
keep it out of young bronze hands
Danvers on the scrolls strike a truce
and they fly off to find Marvel's power
source before the creek and snatch it
away once aboard Marvel's orbiting space
lab Danvers Fury Rambo Talos and goose
find a power source that
our act also known as a space stone but
that isn't the only secret that lab
holds as Talos his family and a bunch of
other scroll refugees are aboard having
lived there for the last six years the
reunion is interrupted by young rock and
the rest of Star Force Danvers has
captured and plugged into the supreme
intelligence who taunts Tambor's about a
rediscovered humanity saying that being
human sucks
wrong move Danvers overcomes a supreme
intelligence and the breaks free of the
Kree suppression of a super powers
meanwhile Fury and Talos beat up some
Kree warriors with relative ease when
you think about the alleged Crete
reigning and all and make their escape
from the lab in the process juice
reveals himself to not be a caste but
rather a Fleur Caen an alien sight gag
able to swallow magical MacGuffins with
the help of CGI tentacles the tesseract
is safe with in his belly and the gang
leaves allowed to head back to earth
Danvers now more powerful than ever
beats up star force blasts yon rug and
explodes some super bombs deployed by
Ronan the accuser the Kree leave Earth
and Danvers does likewise to help the
Skrull refugees find a new home and end
the kree-skrull war for good she leaves
fury a souped up pager to be used only
for emergencies finally in the mid
credit scene we see her return to Earth
20 years later or the activated pager
sits an Avengers headquarters so now
that we know what happens in the movie
what's it all mean
during the beginning of the film young
Rob tells Danvers she needs to dampen
her emotions and control herself under
powers he tells her she needs to be the
best version of herself but the best
version by his standards as we see
memories of her past we see others
telling Danvers what she must do or what
she can't do she needs to slow down a
go-kart she needs to quit basic training
she needs to accept that flying is for
men not women and finally during her
last confrontation with the Supreme
intelligence she needs to accept that
without the Kree she's only human and
that's not enough to succeed
naturally Danvers realizes that
everyone's been dead wrong
being a woman never stopped her from
being a kick-ass pilot or being an
emotional human help to beat all of Star
Force single-handedly if you didn't
catch the intended theme of the film by
that point no doubts I'm just a girl
playing during the fight scene with Star
Force might have driven the point of the
movie hi
and by finally letting loose and
embracing her humanity emotions and all
Danvers discovers she can literally fly
no plane or spaceship required in short
at the ending of the movie proves that
you shouldn't let anyone tell you that
you need to fight against your nature to
be your best self your best self it
might be exactly who you already were
all along with six Infinity stones
floating around the edges of twenty-one
different movies no one would blame you
for having a hard time keeping track of
all of them as such you probably weren't
the only one to gasp in recognition and
confusion when the tesseract showed up
in Marvel's secret floating Space Lab
the last time we saw that thing it was
sitting pretty on Thanos as Infinity
Gauntlet having been liberated from
Loki's possession at the beginning of
Avengers infinity war and before that it
played important roles in the first
Captain America and Avengers movies so
how'd it end up in Marvel's possession
only later to be swallowed and coughed
up by an alien space cats for those who
don't recall the tesseract is up to Red
Skull into space at the end of Captain
America the First Avenger later Howard
Stark recovered the tesseract on the
bottom of the ocean while searching for
the lost Steve Rogers and eventually it
was given to shield for safekeeping the
next time the tesseract appears in the
Avengers film when Loki breaks into
shield headquarters to steal it its
appearance in Captain Marvel fills in
some blanks in terms of the tesseract
importance in shaping the MC use future
however it does raise some questions no
one at shield wondered where the glowing
blue space cubed disappeared to what
kind of paperwork did dr. Lawson have to
fill out in order to gain access that a
tesseract for our experiments file
transfer how large there are several
cool ways Captain Marvel establishes
itself within the MC use crater
continuity the movie does a pretty good
job of ensuring that little if anything
happening in the film contradicts any of
the movies that take place after it
that's a feat many prequels attempt and
at which only a few really succeed for
instance we now know how fury lost his
eye from a nasty scratch by the Fleur
King Kurt the scratch solves a longtime
MCU mystery while also helping us
understand how and why Fury is able to
cope with all the weirdness of super
people without breaking a sweat
he lost his eye to an alien tentacle cat
while escaping a bunch of murderous Kree
soldiers he can handle a few
gods we also learned that the name to
the Avengers initiative was inspired by
Carol Danvers whose callsign as a pilot
was Avenger Fiore super pager which he
used to contact captain marvel at the
end of Avengers infinity war gets an
origin story - in all numbers and a
quest had a definitive impact on Fiore
personally and the larger and folding of
the MCU and yet the pages still raises
at least one huge question about what
defines an emergency - Nick Fury in
Avengers for instance a wormhole opened
over Manhattan and pooped out a bunch of
alien invaders
the second Avengers movie featured a
super evil robot attempting a world
takeover and an entire city floating in
the sky
those weren't emergencies MCU boss Kevin
Feige offered an answer to that question
during the weekend of Captain Marvel's
release when asked by slash film why
fury never hid the pager during those
other crises Feige answered how do you
know he never hit her how do we know he
never pushed it before we've never seen
him push it before that doesn't mean he
never did the mid-credits scene in
Captain Marvel gives us a preview of
Avengers endgame Danvers swoops into
Avengers HQ in response to Fury's pager
which has been sending a signal into
space since infinity war's end it
confirms that Captain Marvel will have a
significant role in the restoration of
half the universe's population good
thing she wasn't dusted to be on mass
it's likely we'll get more adventures
with Captain Marvel on earth once end
games credits roll while she's unlocked
most if not all of her pre cream
memories she still hasn't spent time we
acclimating to life on her homeworld the
events of Captain Marvel take place in
1995 six years after her abduction
now she's returned home after another 20
years though she still looks as young as
ever thanks to her super-powered creep
Lud and just like Captain America before
her Danvers is out of her own time and
we all probably see her struggling to
reconnect after over a quarter century
away from home additionally Monica
Rambeau Maria's daughter probably has a
role to play based on the characters
history from the comics in 1982 she made
her debut as a hero named Captain Marvel
although her origin story didn't really
have anything to do with Danvers Marvel
or the Kree in the MCU though she'll be
20 years older and probably ready to
either join Captain Marvel on her next
adventure
or become her own Captain Marvel further
down the line
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]